question à l'idée de quelle candidature
présidentielle marine le pen est
tellement joué à moi je sais ouais alors
à l'idée d'aller rejouer de la
candidature de cyril hanouna pour 2022
alors j'ai pas compris encore elle est
habitée sur france inter - compris comme
benjamin biolay schirrhein demandé par
le dos marine le pen aussi j'ai demandé
par le dos gratuit rien de mourir elle
était elle a évoqué l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 et je sais pas
pourquoi elle s'est mise à parler de moi
voilà un qu'on paye c'est vraiment des
ailes s'échauffer yoga tai entre hanouna
moi j'ai toutes les concurrences me vont
hanouna je sais pas qui les chanteuse
camilla jordana voilà allez venez tous
est candidat à la présidentielle ça
s'appelle la démocratie c'est sain et
peut-être d'ailleurs serein se sera-t-il
plus gai c'est plutôt dark age c'est
surtout tard car quel mépris ou l'a mal
en quoi le mépris non qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire voilà elle veut
bien se présenter contre tomber sur elle
pour elle elle est tellement sûr de
gagner c'est que nadal à roland garros
elle dit venez me voir c'est comme moi
au paddle abonnés joué contre moi vous
moins bon ben voilà on est la marine le
pen du padel gommer ou non merci on bat
bollaert à mériel à recevoir vos dents
balances ton pote arrive à peine à way
ah oui je vous l'avais invité ou pas je
pense qu'on va l'on va on va essayer de
l'abitibi savait qu'elle va venir ça
c'est sûr parce que je pense que et
époux on va voir si elle a le courage de
venir mario vote parce qu'elle va être
bousculé quand même avec toute l'équipe
qui a je vous rappelle l'année prochaine
balance compotes et l'équipe de fou
encore voilà autour de la table et c'est
vrai que voilà j'aimerai bien géré à y
apprendre pour vraiment la m voilà
devant ses idées voilà et parce que
c'est vrai que je trouve que je ne sais
pas voilà et c'est vrai que qu'elle
marine le pen maintenant elle est assez
rompu à l'exercice vraiment faire
séjourner lui pose des questions
voilà il c'est normal c'est leur métier
qu'elle connaît un petit peu c'est
comment la dent balances ton post est
vrai que c'est un autre exercice et je
pense que on verrait peut-être son vrai
visage
l'animal politique voulait l'ennuyer
invités marion maréchal-le pen
ah oui j'ai vu sa vidéo d'ailleurs c'est
bon on va pas invité non plus s'appelle
balances ton post est pas boulet du post
mais sauf que là elle fait de la com en
fait elle prend à contre-pied des autres
mais paris se bouchent le nez quand on
parle de bigard d'afida turner ou de
vous est elle au contraire elle va avoir
l'air très cool très sympathique genre
pour la démocratie c'est très bien j'ai
bien joué
tout le monde sait bien qu'on vous dit
c'est bien jouer justement faut pas
tomber dans ce piège là parce que la
divise elle essaye de diviser les gens
pour qui divise leur vote et à la fin va
se retrouver parce qu'elle est quand
même le plus grand parti de france
le front national c'est le plus grand
parti où ils vont rester soudés il ya
beaucoup de gens qui votent pour le
front national dont cas divise comme
salehi votez pour qui vous voulez c'est
pas innocent comme ça elle est encore au
deuxième tour et rebelote donc pas
innocent mais ça ne s'est pas innocent
ce qu'elle veut elle a toujours un petit
côté quand même assez méprisant là dans
ses propos mais nous allons leur rappel
quand même de la manipulation est aussi
la récupération là c'est de la démagogie
jusqu'à locales qu elle est belle et
forte pour ça justement c'est une grande
oratrice et elle sait très bien manier
fait de la démagogie n'a qu'a bien de la
démagogie c'est pas mon genre
jmp si c'est votre jour nous on aime la
sofico ce qui pue des pieds mais camilla
mais justement pour rebondir sur toutes
les candidatures via make sur facebook
et un caddie quand je pense qu'au
deuxième tour jusqu'aux objets de beauté
bio pour faire barrage à afida turner
[Rires]